what's up with y'all man it's rifle nine
y'all catch me driving four guys two
this April man catch me on bootleg cab
podcast too man Drop it today watch it
today man Turn Me Up
yo bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here ski representing New Orleans we've
got Rob 49 ladies and gentlemen stuff
where we are man it's not playing one of
my favorite new artists man you've been
doing your thing for the last few years
so Lou glad to finally have you here I
always wanted to come in you always tell
I was just telling you uh your music is
like uh it gives me hype bruh yeah you
got records of like if I played football
I'd be willing to crack them
to your records you know
what I'm saying yeah it was definitely
yeah
first of all how long have you been
doing this rap for real for real
kind of like two years
two like two years now
that's it yeah that's it
wouldn't you record your first song
I recorded my first song
on a pandemic hit
really yeah I swear to God
you're pretty good at this man I know I
don't know how I got that good bro I'll
be looking at myself like that I don't
know how I got that good I swear to God
so how do you go from just starting the
rap to just kind of catching on fire so
fast like what what was the moment or
the song or the particular meeting or
what was it that kind of changed
everything for you
um probably in my city like I ain't
gonna lie like in my city I've been
hiding my citizens on first job like so
it it was already that I think vulture
Island was the one that really liked of
course not a matter of fact it wasn't
volcano was Hustler okay Hustler that's
the song that really did it maybe like
oh this hard like and it's crazy to
think that like with all of the history
in New Orleans when it comes to Hip Hop
I feel like in Louisiana Baton Rouge has
really had a run over the last decade
and I feel like you're kind of like one
of the first like New Orleans artists in
a while that has like really caught
National like
um since Wayne for real for real for
real yeah nobody like
it's crazy too yeah it's like such a uh
New Orleans is the greatest it's one of
my favorite places I've ever visited I
love it there
um what area are you from
um downtown okay I have a project design
project
so I went to uh
where do we go eat hot wings no there
was a hot wing place that the dude from
do you remember the group juvenile was
in UTP
skip skip he owned a hot wing place what
that is man
chicken oh you want the chicken and
water yes and it was so good they had a
lot they had a dream they had a bunch of
drinks named after famous people they
had like Obama juice and Oprah juice
well no I ain't gonna lie taking the
watermelon some of the best wings in the
city bro some of the best movies I've
ever had nah them crazy yeah you got me
one too that was so good damn bro
yeah and I remember just going in there
like oh yeah the dude from UTP was this
place I was like what what's the spots
to eat out too
I don't know
honestly bro if I'm gonna be honest I
hear like LA's food situation is
probably a little overrated I'm gonna go
to boy Boiling Crab boy I want the bull
I think that's what it's called where
they have the bag of seafood no not boil
boil boa like some like that oh boa
the steakhouse yeah yeah I mean it's a
steakhouse but they had a crab they had
a crab that was cut on both sides so all
you gotta do is this to the crab fall
right now well that's the best man
this is so good they used to do a brunch
out here at the Four Seasons I don't
know if they still do it but it's like
150 a person yeah you go in and they
have king crab legs already open for you
the hardest though is opening the
crab bruh I ain't never used to
like opening crowds I ain't never used
to like even having crabs because I
ain't know how to open them and then
you'll cut yourself open them it's a
pain in the ass when I learned how to do
it though that's all I want to eat yeah
crabs are amazing I mean y'all be
eating all the crawfish and
out there in New Orleans damn you got me
on crawfish no I can't do the Crawfish
it's something about the eyes I can't do
it I can do all the other shellfish in
the world it's crazy bro like that's the
best that better than crab
that better than everything really
I swear from New Orleans I've never
tried it everywhere else is trash
everywhere in this world trade I had the
um what's y'all type of sandwiches the
po boys I had those from what I've been
in Oilers twice well you went to jeans
jeans I don't even know bro you didn't
go to jeans you didn't really do nothing
man they said jeans down the rest of the
piece I went to some spot
um in the French Quarter for sure nah
yeah nah you probably went to Acme or
something I don't know I know that there
was like a place with green grenade
drinks oh you went to the hand grenade
please yeah and um that was the first
time I had ever seen a car on like 32
inch rims
man yeah we don't be doing it out there
no it I saw it in New Orleans it was a
no usually ran into somebody
that's the whole frame of the car to fit
the wheels on oh yeah I seen a couple
dudes do that like I just seen one dude
do that man I got this man cut the we
hit every bump we hit it felt like we
hit a speed boat right because like
there's no way that's just not practical
I can't yes if something else was like
there's dunks and then there's whatever
that is that's something else uh but
it's crazy because you uh
being one of the first guys since Wayne
to really put on nationally out of New
Orleans not to say that there aren't
other artists by the way shout out to
currency who's a legend Anderson
yeah but he's got a new album out with
uh JD that's coming soon so I'm gonna
shout out to spitter but you had
Birdman
pass you the Baton on the intro your
album man that's crazy huh I didn't even
realize how crazy that was until like
two months ago told me that I'm
like you have Third Man passing
you the torch officially on
record
that shit's crazy
how did you like how does that happen
like like
um I don't know I just asked him to send
me some it was in the studio and he
said he like that's what I want
you know kick the album off that's what
I want
and he was like I want to do this for
you yeah he just he told me the other
day like I won't be on everything you
ever released like
Birdman was one of the first people were
leaving me though like two months and
three months until it happened he called
me like you the one like he didn't try
signing you then he tried to sign he was
the first person trying to sign me it
just didn't work out
well
like keep my eye was too much to rap and
I I ain't released number one tape like
I got released I I got I got signed at
the three tapes the tape that I had was
called I quit because I was about to
stop rapping okay and the day I got my
cover off for a birdman called me maybe
I won't sign you me up you flew me
to Cali we just lost touch in like the
next week or some like that I had
wound up doing say cheese I ain't even
know it would say cheese but then Sean
brought me to leave when Capital One to
sign me and then I was going back and
forth the leg was then so like yeah
what made you eventually like for you
because I'm sure it's got to be kind of
cool to be courted like that it almost
probably feels like similar to like a
NBA free agent feels like when they're
trying to sign into a you know a team
like how cool was that just having like
a little bidding work going for you uh
I don't know I'm ready for the next one
you know okay I'm gonna fulfill this
deal and then we go double back I had
like 10 000 followers and like
so they my labor called me before
anything like you know what I'm saying
so they kind of they they got they
looked up like you know what I'm saying
they got in early yeah they got in there
at least they believed in you earlier
they believed the mirror that's why
that's why I ain't gonna lie like
that's why with this live I'm at right
now like I don't know anyone lead them
because they believed in me like that
that means a lot you know for sure for
sure man
um at what point in time did you realize
like vulture Island was like
an Anthem for for just a lot of people
like it's it's a it's an Anthem in the
club it's anthem when it comes to NFL
players I just realized that like last
week at boosted Bass
they attacked me like man you got an
Anthem like is she gonna be around for a
minute like
I even understand it though I said crazy
because that still in the club I
ain't drop I ain't dropping a year right
like no way I'm still down there in my
head like no way I'm still relevant like
but this is still popping highest
popping been popping like what was
bougie bash like
is crazy that's just that's home though
so of course yeah
you know I always try to boost I always
say he's one of the few guys that if you
love him when you meet him you will not
be disappointed no Captain because
that's him that's him bro for sure
I'll be him because you meet some guys
and they're like oh you ain't who I grew
up look you meet boozy and you're like
oh no this is you he's a he's such a
good dude too and he's so funny like you
gotta try to
during the pandemic him in trouble rest
in peace to trouble they were doing
these pool parties I'm sure you saw the
footage did you ever see any of the
footage of the trouble boozy pool
parties with all the damn cucumbers
all these sucking on cucumbers
yeah I'm trying to go to this yeah bro I
don't know man you got to stay out of
there man what I just feel like you know
you'll get you go you don't want to
around with the wrong over there I
mean you don't want to with no
sucking on cucumbers bruh Facebook
you got your whole life ahead of you man
don't throw it away for a cucumber bro
you know what I mean
that's my type of point I like that type
of you a strip club guy
um I wanna be
that's something to Aspire to be I want
to be it's like
I just can't go to the club like you
know what I'm saying something in my
head not letting me go to the club
you're smart you're smart yeah stay out
the club man I was worth it before I was
rapping I ain't never been to the club
like really I wasn't old enough so how
old are you now 2400 me 24 like so like
you never like really started to hit the
club until you were getting booked yeah
that's the time to go when there's a bag
to pick up that's what I'm telling you
like stay out bro that's what I'm saying
I remember I tried to go to a club one
time in my city
it was so hectic for us to get in right
that was already I was already letting
my sit around the time I'm like man I
plan on be like
I said you know what I told bro I'm on
my way man let's go I see next time we
come here they're gonna give us all
their money
it's crazy because when I went to New
Orleans we uh one of my friends is a
photographer his name is John John and
uh he he like we kind of went to so
where the levees broke for Katrina
there's like that neighborhood right on
the other side that got hit really bad
yeah so we just went over there and we
got invited uh this lady invited us into
our house cooked us dinner explained to
us like how everything happened with
Katrina like how uh do you remember back
because you were obviously a kid when
all that happened I remember everything
though I remember the day happened what
was that like man going through that I'm
lying for us it was it was crazy because
we ain't had no like working a reliable
car at the moment right so we're driving
to um Houston like we was driving in the
Monte Carlo I remember the windows was
tinted but the doors didn't um I mean
the windows didn't go down and that
ain't working that no AC and it's
running hot it's it's definitely humid
as because you're in New Orleans
it's hot as it's the middle of this
hot and sticky yeah it's it's no AC the
windows don't roll down in a car running
hot we was rolling we was riding with
the doors open on the interstate just to
get some air just to get some in that
bridge running hot every 15 minutes so
you guys ended up going to Houston how
long were you guys in Houston how long
was in Houston for
three months yeah because I know a lot
of people that was kind of like the main
place that they would reloc relocate to
came to Phoenix too I know some you know
these things keep falling off velcro
boys we gotta velcro these things on you
know man I fixed this me
um no but it's kind of crazy like like
did that did
um Katrina like hit your neighborhood
pretty bad yeah and they hit the whole
New Orleans yeah
it's wild I wasn't I'm I'm I was
standing a project though so it's like
we we on bricks right so he ain't really
up too bad because it's bricks
like you know high up yeah yeah it's
high up like my house ain't really get
up yeah
yeah that's crazy who else in New
Orleans right now should we be paying
attention to what other rappers can we
can we shed some light on that you think
um
um black Migo
um Nino Calvin treaty
um lodgy
Road ruggy
um big pack
lots of lots of talents a lot I got a
lot of coming up
this this but I might do I might still
try to sign or this and like how
this rap name TG he hard as you're
gonna start trying to sign some artists
yeah I'm gonna sign a couple of them
it's crazy too because like I think
about like
like New Orleans and Baton Rouge to me
have such a different sound from each
other if we think about just like
historical context and rap like
New Orleans listen I got this one all of
the mother son dog you he gonna do an
interview here one day
he's from New Orleans he's from New
Orleans dog he's so does he know he's
about to get signed to you
I've been telling them and but I
ain't never really like you know what
I'm saying but then you're so hard
tell her pull up man what's this okay
come do a freestyle or something bro all
right that's what we're gonna do let's
do it you're gonna be surprised because
he started rapping in December
this December just came you start having
to December it's like three months ago
what's in the I mean what's in the water
out there I'm about to tell you
yeah this is one of my closest friends
okay so it was I had got an Airbnb in
Miami
and I was recording with him but I
wanted some of my partners to rap so he
sat down in the chum like more if you're
not taking a serious move these dudes
really trying to make songs right he
ain't I'm I'm gonna make a song
for real too
Moe was the first per he linked with he
linked me with my first producer to make
my first song and he used to be going to
sleep with my music on his chest
this is like your OG this is nice it's
like your like one of your best friends
like your guy yeah like yeah but he
rapping on this like what the how
you sound as good
it's a blessing guys I always like to
have two partners rapping like this
that's fire what's the name do you know
what the name of your imprint's gonna be
kind of like about to cut to vulture
cartel I've always got to avulture I
think you should I think it should be
vulture anything else but cartel
you know it's fine I was about to tell
you that I'm trying to stay away from
that because stay away from the word
gang cartel
stay away from all that man just
vulture Inc well I don't know
anything
vulture LLC vulture Incorporated I know
bro cause you never know bro these
is watching they'll be
like look it's it's a cartel
bro
damn dog cause too many of you have been
telling me this soon like it's it's just
what it is God change it's bootleg cab
here gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our good friends at King Palm
now listen guys all I do is smoke out of
King Palm if you see me smoking it's out
of King Palm all right and I'm gonna
shout them out because it's all natural
no tobacco to tobacco-free uh product
also no additives no need to split it
open no need to lick it comes ready to
go all you have to do
is put your uh your tree your flower of
choice right into here and you're good
to go now the best thing about King Palm
they have these turbine enough infused
wraps right here they're flavored uh
this is my favorite I do love watermelon
all right burst of watermelon flavor
again no tobacco no additives all
natural all you got to do is pack it and
you aren't ready to go now this is
what's dope about King Palm if you go to
the website right now you know they're
the new sponsor I've been using them
forever so I had to hit them up like hey
guys I'm tired of smoking you guys a
I'd love some support on the
podcast of course all right so go to
kingpom.com right now use the promo code
bootleg Kev and You're Gonna Save 50 off
um you can get whatever you need you can
order it online because these are
tobacco free no nicotine baby all right
you can get it right to your house half
off kingpom.com keyword bootleg heavy
you can also hit your local 7-Eleven you
could also hit your local smoke shop one
of the best selling brands in America at
the smoke shop so many different
products rollable wraps hemp cones all
the smoking accessories one would ever
need the smoothest smoke the easiest to
use
what are you doing if you're
smoking and you're smoking at anything
but this you're crazy all right
go check them out online socials one
more time kingpom.com promo code bootleg
save half off taking you on that natural
path King pong baby hey also shout out
to the homies at Blue chew man don't
forget if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction if you're a penis is not
functioning correctly
it's a little flaccid you're trying to
get it a little hard a lot of hard
rather bluetooth's where it's at a lot
of people ask me you always talk about
Bluetooth does it work yes it works all
right uh listen it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra anacialis but it's
in a chewable form all right it is sent
right to your door uh in a discrete
package it's a great thing man go to
bluetooth.com right now you use that
promo code bootleg right now you're
gonna get a month supply for free of
Bluetooth why not have some better sex
okay seriously uh there's so many other
ways you can get down too because they
just dropped the Bluetooth mint flavor
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra just so many things we can do
here uh and look when you go to
bluetooth.com and you sign up with that
promo code bootleg they're gonna
literally send it straight to your crib
for free five dollars in shipping you
get a month supply for free now how does
it work one you don't need to go to any
doctor's appointments it's all handled
online with an online pharmacist you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room to go discuss
your dick with some strange dude or
chick hmm maybe you're into that I don't
know with that being said it's an
awkward situation all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction all
you need to do is go to bluetooth.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you'll get one month supply for free
zero dollars right to your door your
wife Weaver never know it even happened
you know what I'm saying maybe you've
been a little embarrassed you're tired
of piping down that same old bra that
you've been sleeping with for the last
35 years put a little pep in your step
man take a Bluetooth use that promo code
bootleg bluetooth.com and try it for
free also got a shout out to my bookie
man Final Four Is On The Way NBA
playoffs are here well almost here we
got like a few games left right so much
going on you got the Masters coming up
man so many ways to win money
join us in my bookie I've been using my
bookie for about a decade now it's where
I put all my bets in uh there's so many
ways to win money with my bookie if you
go to my bookie right now you sign up
mybookie.ag promo code bootleg and you
will get
double deposit bonus action that means
your very first deposit up to a thousand
dollars make that deposit with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up for
that new account and they're going to
give you uh uh another thousand dollars
they're gonna double your first deposit
so you might put 200 in you might put
500 in they will give you another 200
another 500 to gamble with all right so
much to do with my bookie obviously we
love betting on sports literally one of
my biggest passions in life is gambling
away my money and winning money on
mybookie.ag now I got a few Futures
going on right now I got Joelle EMB
doing the MVP I got the Phoenix Suns to
win the West I got the Bucks to win the
East NCAA action I'm taking UConn all
the way what are y'all doing go to my
bookie right now they got the props you
can do the player props you can do the
over unders you can do whatever you need
plus live Blackjack live roulette I have
so much fun on my bookie you really
don't ever need to leave your house
shout out to my booking mybookie.ag sign
up right now with the promo code bootleg
and get that first deposit bonus
what are we talking about who else is
going to double your first deposit
ladies and gentlemen mybookie.ag promo
code bootleg sign up and let's win some
money now let's get back to the
interview so when you obviously if
you're not rapping growing up like what
was kind of like your game plan as a kid
were you playing sports you were playing
basketball okay I was telling myself I
wanted to be a good kid bro
I always wanted to be a good kid like
all the that I was that was going
on around me I always wanted to be good
it wasn't until high school when I
really started doing like bad like
like you know what I'm saying like
probably like 10th grade just being bad
in the ships being a badass kid I just
wanted to be good though you know what
I'm saying
it's I'm thankful that I'm here right
now you don't care
because I I always wanted to make it out
you have a scar on your face that is a
lot of your fans know what happened
there for people who don't know I had a
cut my cousin had cut me in my face
you guys got into a fight no she she was
playing with me
but she had wound up cutting me with a
brim like
I remember that day I remember every
time
did your cousin get her ass beat by a
parent
um
I had big Boogie on and he's got a big
scar on his forehead and he said when he
was a little kid him and his brother
used to play
some where they would just
each other up so like he said his
brother busted a bottle over his head
for real or something I was like bro
what kind what were y'all doing like
okay I think I said it yeah I think I
said it yeah I was like bro like what
was going on like like my mom came home
and my brother up nah nah nah I
would think I would think she got
up about it because she was older
choose order so so you uh you got the
new record out with the baby yeah he
spazzed out I love the White lives
matter line that was hilarious
funny man I ain't gonna lie I'm so
appreciative of him though cause he one
of the first people who started
my right like he put I saw him
coming on The Voice Island first like
he they went on that do you like
well first of all shout out to the baby
who's an incredible artist you guys are
our label mates as well what was uh the
process of getting that record done was
it just sending it over you son's in the
school
yeah he's on Interscope yeah I did not
know that yeah no it wasn't even a
process he just was in mind he was in
Miami like where you at I'm like I'm in
Miami he said I'm putting up on you
tonight that's it we just did it it was
on our own type time knocked it out even
with the video like it was we it was
just me and him the whole time that's
amazing because usually you know how it
is with these a lot of bigger artists
there's like the middle man or there's
like I don't like that though right
because I make time for what I want so
was it um as easy of a process to get a
little baby on the vulture Island remix
it was it was really part of the easiest
I ain't had it like we ain't make up
with nothing it just he just handled it
sent it over send him the open version
and he returned it returned it did a
video whenever I wanted to do it like
she was easy do you remember like uh the
first time you realized vulture Island
was like viral
or was like really moving was it like
somebody had posted it or somebody you
saw somebody
like I I never realized but I ain't
gonna lie you're just kind of living in
it I just know it's about not because I
go people listening to it but it's like
I ain't never new episodes of all right
yeah everything that would give me that
Vibe like oh yeah we going dumb you know
no no
uh what's up with your boy Zion
Williamson man can we get him on the
basketball court all right Zion my love
has he tapped in with you yeah that's my
real dog like
you guys are friends yes
he'd be back soon man he just hurt right
now how did you guys connect I mean
obviously he's probably a fan but like
um I had to do a private party
you did it you threw a private party I
threw a private party popped up on me
he seems like a nice guy nah for sure
for sure he's very talented was the he
just injured all the time I know
he's gonna be straight dude I I think he
just I don't know I really don't know
what's up with it all right so like
you're growing up as a kid watching the
Pelicans you probably like at that time
Anthony Davis is like the guy man listen
I'm a real Pelican fan like Jay-Z said
they go over 82 tonight hey I appreciate
that because I'm a real Suns fan and the
suns were very bad up until like two
years ago so so you've been riding with
the Pelicans yeah what bro like nobody
can't tell me nothing about the pellet
guns bro through holiday days holiday
Chris Paul like yeah whatever we went
through well when Chris Paul was there
it was the Hornets yeah but I was
defense too I remember they changed to
the Pelicans I had I was like I should
have left it at the harness like the
Hornets were fired the harness was fired
while we changed that bro well y'all got
Pelicans out there though the Pelican
flag we don't got Pelicans bro I saw one
Pelican wait there's no Pelicans in
New Orleans I saw one Pelican
bro this is this isn't a try and that
was this year Boo this is it was last
year bro what a terrible name for a
franchise if there's no Pelicans
they don't even have hornets out there
I mean we knew that this should have
named the voodoo or something the voodoo
is the voodoo real in New Orleans
yeah this definitely
because you can feel it in there yeah
when you guard that you could smell it
like
it's just it's just a feeling out there
like do you know out there
be putting Voodoo hexes on
or I don't know I don't know I don't
think so not that I know of if there is
I would want to know yeah because I
won't I won't do Voodoo People
you would do some voodoo on somebody
yeah for sure you cast a spell yeah good
spell them like what kind of never see
the best would you ever make a like
maybe make a chick Fall in Love with You
cast that spell
um
my best but just make everything go how
I wanted to go I think it's it's safe to
say it's going pretty well for you if a
girl fall in love with you bro like me
girlfriend bro you excellent you asking
for something that you really don't want
bro girls crazy bro but if you cast a
spell it could be any girl it could be
Nicki JLo you don't want Nikki in love
with you needed like bro if a girl that
loves you bro she she brother she crazy
bro I don't want no girl that crazy with
me so you are trying to prevent women
from falling in love with you actively
um
just
not right now it's a cool and love okay
not knowing Voodoo in love Voodoo in
love is like boy I do anything right
that's like Christian rock crazy yeah I
don't like that yeah that's crazy to me
yeah you don't want a girl with your
face tatted on there
yeah that I wouldn't respect that she
tagged up my table right there Christian
rock with a knife
that's her that's her artwork
C plus J forever J is Jonathan blueface
oh she's great
she started a heart
bro it was a I don't have a knife
don't do it with your nail bruh
I tried concerned is this a this is a
great chain you have here uh how new is
this chain
um this person like December that
is serious
do you feel like because I do feel like
when we see a lot of young artists we
always hear kind of financially they
make decisions when they first get a lot
of money that they regret are you being
pretty smart with your money I'm being
British what are you doing with it I did
not want to buy this thing okay just
because I know like man this cost a
lot for nothing like right bro tax
write-off exactly a prop prop right I
remember like being in a project like
man boy 200 000 would have died to have
that money like I just put that on
the Chain bro you tripping room you
spent 200 000 on that no you close to
200. wow
that's a lot so what are you doing with
the rest of your money
buying real estate yeah real estate at
home yeah is that I can imagine the is
the property value pretty pretty low you
can get in pretty low right now
um like they got fixer uppers they got a
lot of fixed up right this this Mike New
Orleans getting gentrified quick right
well I know Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie
had a house at the French quarter right
on live bro they got they got Brad Pitt
and Angela Jolie houses in New Orleans
man you drive past that you gonna
know like oh that's one of the houses
like they crazy like the thought process
on the on a cribs crazy
they got like you can rent out like
oh you could like right now like I'm
saying like Okay properties yeah they're
getting properties out there I think
they got divorced though for real so
somebody one of them two owns the house
now I don't think both of them to do
anymore usually yeah see that's what
happens you fall in love you get married
and then you break up and you have to
give you have to split everything in
half that's one that's I'm not getting
married don't get married because then
you get divorced and the girl gets half
that chain you have to cut that
thing in half I'm not getting married
yeah I'm not trying to get married uh
Rob are you binge watching any TV shows
you dabble in any Netflix or any uh any
shows right now I'll be on that I'll be
on that you heavy you is crazy heavy
I heard money Heist is good but it's in
a different language right you've never
watched it bro you can switch the
language okay I haven't never watched it
no
yeah lucky bro so do you do you read the
subtitles you switch the language can I
switched the language but then the mouth
moves and the words don't line up that
should be fine sometimes I don't even
look at it like that no more I just look
I just look at it like
you know what I'm saying you don't even
like you know I did that moment looking
at the emote for real I did that with a
you're not looking if you watch a
regular game I did that with Squid game
I put the English on for real squid game
do you see squid game yeah so I did
watch it that way the mouth yeah you
gotta just don't look at it money Heist
fire if you're watching a regular movie
on Netflix you're not looking at them
out bro the only reason you looking at
them up because you know because you
kind of know you see what I'm saying you
watch a snowfall nah everybody keep
telling me about snowfall it's pretty
good that's it they're good yeah it's
not a Netflix though so how many seasons
do you get six six and final season
that's the final season like they're not
making no more no more you ever watched
Breaking Bad how many episodes per
season like 10 to 12. snowfall
10 to 12. you gotta watch Breaking Bad
it's the it's top two show ever
it's about a teacher he's a chemistry
teacher
so he's a chemist he finds out he has
like a illness where he's going to die
yeah so he decides to start cooking and
selling meth on the side with one of his
old students so he becomes like a
drug kingpin
and his family has no idea why he's
still teaching High School
it's crazy some gangster
for real is wild
you got to tap it so money Heist I gotta
watch money Heist you gotta watch
Breaking Bad I'm gonna watch snowfall no
snowfall watch Breaking Bad very
much man this is It's on Netflix too you
just you already got Netflix obviously
you just go right on Netflix type in
Breaking Bad just dive in I got you
playing any video games but I've been on
Madden heavy really I've been on Madden
heavy I don't know why what's your team
on there at the Saints upload the Chiefs
the Saints trash that's my favorite team
but they trash bro yeah I mean even when
they had you breeze on Matt and I I
didn't know how to play with him yeah I
mean I like running quarterbacks I don't
even know who who's the quarterback now
oh Jameis resigned and then they they're
a car Derek Derek Carr another guy who
can't run so you still won't be picking
the Saints will you I wanted Lamar
Jackson so bad bro he's probably going
to Atlanta you think going to Atlanta I
think so
division rival
I hate Atlanta bruh
is Kamara tapped in with you at all yeah
that's my dog I feel like he's uh is he
always wearing a cash money chain or am
I tripping yeah or no it's a QC chain
it's QC you gotta catch money chain two
I think I think Birdman told me I can't
imagine
any advice Birdman gave you that stuck
with you
pick and choose what you do is it he
gonna stay in the street or you're gonna
rap
one or the other one another he said
ain't gonna work for you if you're doing
bro so be both feet in ten toes in on
the rap that's what I did the gym
ten tours and then that work that's
working out man
have you linked with Wayne at all
nah you know we can't cross paths but we
ain't never speaking nothing like that
for you like growing up Hoosier like
give me your like top four New Orleans
artists ever because there's some
Legends obviously free BG
New Orleans artists flame game Flow
Lil Wayne
Nino Calvin
oh my full one is
who I grew up listening to for real from
New Orleans
probably like no juvenile huh nah I'm
probably like probably like killing
brother
like that's the real New Orleans like
I'm talking about like
you know people look at New Orleans and
like all the Cash Money No Limit I'm
talking about the real New Orleans right
now New Orleans
Kenny brother flame game Floyd and Lil
Wayne that's him right right now I'm
over that though like
now it's you no it's me now it's you man
when's the next uh the next album coming
out obviously you drop something last
year wasn't extra kind of like April so
coming soon the end of April who else is
on the album besides the baby
they're going now
got no cap on now that's all I ain't
trying to go ahead with the field I have
no cap yeah yeah no caps so so cold bruh
no it's my dog Nicole where's he from
Alabama you
yeah no he from um
he's from Alabama
yeah
I think he is from Alabama no he is
Alabama
um
Alabama yeah he's from Alabama from
Alabama
Mississippi no no he from Alabama he's
from Alabama yeah
rallo's fire yeah hey we got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at Odd Socks baby that's
right shout out to Odd Socks little
Godfather sock right there craziest
licenses in the game the most
comfortable socks period And if you go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
20 off at checkout now they also got the
underwear going on these are some Street
Fighter draws let's pop these boys open
check them out
oh yeah oh yeah a little Chun Lee versus
Blanco
what
amazing
do you like Yoo-hoo so much that you'd
wear Yoo-hoo on your feet
there's people running around out here
with goddamn hot Cheeto jumpsuits right
now so of course you would shout out to
you who they got crazy licenses we
already mentioned Street Fighter
Coca-Cola Pepsi yes they got the they
got the both there they got Pepsi and
Coca-Cola uh they also got Scarface
Breaking Bad WWE so many dope licenses
plus their Odd Socks Basics line which
are these just kind of the normal socks
in my opinion are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet
I promise you you gotta go to
autotoxofficial.com right now and use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off your
entire order all right so go do that
oddsoxofficial.com also want to give a
shout out to our family at hardean
that's right Harding the craziest
dispensary you've ever walked into in
your life Hardy in Las Vegas you got to
pull up follow them on Instagram Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see the Hat you
see the logo shout out to the family at
hardean if you're in Vegas you got to
stop off you got to go pick you up some
weed it is legal in Vegas tell them I
sent you they're gonna take care of you
all right uh make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the largest
selection of previous cannabis I've ever
seen in my life the best smelling place
I've ever walked into in my life they
have a signature scent that's
insane so shout out to hardine go follow
him Harding underscore Las Vegas check
out more info about them at
jardinlasvegas.com let's get back to the
interview
for you like have you noticed like um
because I do feel like when you start
popping in the South there's like
there's like this whole part of the
country that you could just get money in
right yeah but then you come to like LA
and it's different and it's different or
you come to like certain parts of the
West Coast Seattle whatever it's a lot
different because I you know I'll book
artists and somebody will try to hit me
upside ahead with the with the uh the
the South Park with the South price oh
my gosh guys yeah yeah I realize the
difference though for sure like I just
went through that we just booked gorilla
in uh AZ and shout out to her she's
great she gave me the easy price she
understood she got it got it kind of
told her like hey you know like you got
to get the whole country
so for you are you like are you pretty
cognizant of that for sure for sure
because you gotta know where you're
gonna be able to get that that that that
high that high number but you want to
spread it spread out man thanks to him
yeah Facebook I understand
[Music]
that's crazy I know if I come up here
something like damn
this I don't know nothing brought up
here like you know what I'm saying yeah
outside of Louisiana what's your biggest
Market
Houston like Texas H down the whole
Texas for all of Texas all the Texas
would you say well never mind you
haven't have you been to Houston strip
clubs yeah hell yeah area 29 that's my
favorite strip club of all time it's the
honest group Club I go in for free if
you go to area 29 is it a BYOB strip
club in Houston they have the ones where
you can bring your own bottle
um nah every 299 like that but that's
like my family like so right that's
that's the first people that really
popped my record like oh that's fine
um so shout out to H-Town all right so
you got the album on the way you know
the name of the album yet oh God for God
too okay albums coming trippy Reds on it
Dirk's on it no cap
the baby the baby
more music videos coming yeah I won't do
a music video for all them songs
as you should um
and lots of Investments you got some
real estate popping I got it um
uh fragrance
a fragrance cologne yeah um
and perfume
for the for the ladies yeah cause it
metal When we dropped this you got to
put it on the thing submittal we're
gonna drop the link on that you're
smoking I mean obviously right how do
you come up with that like how do you
how do you just like sniff a bunch of
and you're like I like this my dad
would be handling all that now you're
gonna with I'm gonna send you some
matter of fact when I send it to you
gonna have to you're gonna have to have
it up here for me turn me up how do you
spell it
s-e-m-e-t-o okay submetto yeah I like it
are you smoker no let's move you don't
smoke good for you you drink I don't
drink need it for real why is that is
there something else is it because you
just you're not into it or did you grow
up because I don't do a lot of
because I grew up seeing my family doing
that somebody said I think
um
I smoked for the first time when I was
like 12. I think that me up like
it's a bad eight I smoked when I was
eight and I was up it hurt my
I smoke I smoke I smoke I smoke I
smoked before when I was like nine do
you remember when you first did it and
it burnt your throat yeah
because you didn't know what you're
doing yeah I smoked a lot of pipe too
that's the worst my first time I
smoked out of pipe and the second time I
smoked my cousin about some girls damn I
just felt it in my throat yeah it hit
you right in the throat you're like why
would anybody do this it hurts and he
did me a shotgun
because
[Music]
I was walking across the street back to
my house and it's my first time being
high as like you you thinking this
fake
I see a going fast as
man
I hope I walk in front of the car I told
myself like
that might be real though
it might be there for real it might be
that for real so just let that
go ahead so I let him go I
remember that I remember you know
funny I remember it was Thanksgiving you
were high on Thanksgiving mama told me
she she never knew that she said you
high is that your mom yeah oh
Mom's here yeah she said I said no I I
was high as a I went in my
room man I got my big ass Thanksgiving
played on mom did you know he was high
oh you remember that dude
that was hot as
so your cousin gave a shotgun to you
cutting a shotgun me did the cousin get
in trouble Mom did you find out no no I
said no fine yeah well now now we know
yeah
we was high as
it was high as I remember that
that's when it was still selling the
dime bags in a little down bag bag yo I
don't even I the dime bag wave I missed
that whole thing you missed that I mean
I was alive when it was popping but I I
really didn't get you weren't smoking
weed like that until people were just
buying eighths man no bro they had the
dime bag the blue dime bag that looked
like a little bit of Ziploc bag yeah
that's what we had got out they still
sell cocaine in those things
don't do drugs unless it's mushrooms
do Coke man oh your little your homies
do not my home at home but somebody I
know he just he said you're getting
turned up so it gives him a lot of
energy yeah see for me I would just play
your music
your music is like audio cocaine for
real just throw that on and be like
it just ready bro with some
weights bro let's move some bruh
give me a Dolly let's move a
couch man man you I I want to
see some videos you bumping that
man I was buffing that today and I
bent the corner and blast was like yo
you know Blaster singer he was standing
on the corner here I interviewed him
before you came
I'm a fan you seem like you got a great
head on your shoulders you got a bright
future ahead of you new album in April
April and a lot more uh cologne you know
uh you're signing your boy who just
started rapping in December Moschino
you're going to continue the trend of
popping New Orleans rappers who just
started rapping for sure yeah there it
is man I appreciate you pulling up Rob I
appreciate it yes sir
yes sir